[Musique]
d'avenue aux sources du lavandou avec ma
famille on a décidé de suivre de
nouvelles lois s'élevait l'année h petit
bouc
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'elle a grandi manille c'est
incroyable c'est impressionnant doudou
intégrant maintenant 1
j'avais comme tu étais petit
[Musique]
tout
non
on
c'est une belle graines qui pousse
amadou une grande maman 1
en fait ce que je trouve magnifique avec
l'ia et mamie c'est que justement du
fait qu'elle levait grandi et qu'elle
évolue au quotidien entoure est
justement de cette nature ça fait que
tout est normal tout est naturel manille
par exemple à 2 ans elle sait
reconnaître de la consoude de l'ortie du
fenouil dans le jardin etc
et ça c'est assez impressionnant de voir
ce qu'est ce qu'ils sont capables de
développer une cuisine ensemble en émoi
tout fait comme d'hab je coupe et toi tu
mets dans la marmite aucun nous tue vise
bien à l'intérieur des dons et à elle
adore faire la visite du lieu
malheureusement elle n'est pas là
aujourd'hui puisqu'elle est à l'école et
il arrive donc parfois puisqu'on a des
couleuvres sur le terrain on croise la
route de certains et ce qui est drôle
c'est que parfois les donc les visiteurs
eux ont très peur elle fait trop mais
c'est une couleuvre sur la laisse
tranquille à une belle sera tranquille
en retour elle a aucune crainte la plus
grosse appréhension par rapport à l'ia
c'était peut-être qu'elle souffre dans
une différence vis-à-vis de ses
camarades de classe du fait qu'elle ait
une vie hyper différentes et est en fait
c'est trop chouette parce que c'est
devenu au contraire une sorte de
curiosité pour les autres enfants est
une source de fierté pour elle
est ce que vous aimez vivent dans des
cabanes
[Musique]
le bilan deux ans après c'est que ça
nécessite beaucoup d'efforts pour
asseoir notre confort mais que ça fait
tellement du bien faire qu'on se sent
pleinement vivant à la fois dans nos
renforcements musculaires parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'on sait c'est rendu rssi
mais aussi à l'intérieur de nous donc là
c'est deux nouvelle cabale c'est un
petit peu notre rapport à ces lieux du
coup la première fois que vous est donné
sur le lieu on était quatre avec deux
enfants plus à vivre sur le lieu est
maintenant on est 12 donc le fait de
faire des chantiers participatifs et ben
de faire connaître aussi tout ce que la
désobéissance fertile représente ça a
amené beaucoup de vies sur ce lieu à la
fois un passage mais aussi des gens que
kim ont adoré ce mode de vie et qui sont
restés vivre avec nous
[Musique]
toutes les cabanes ici elles sont
construites de la même façon c'est à
dire que c'est du bois pour la structure
la charpente
ensuite des bottes de paille qu'on
agglomère pour monter les murs et
ensuite on enduit d'argile à l'intérieur
et voilà ça fait des constructions ont
dit compostables parce qu'elles peuvent
se dégrader naturellement et surtout
nous on fait des gros déborde toit de
façon à ce qu'ils aient pas d'humidité
qu'ils aillent à l'extérieur des murs de
foin mais on ne les ennuie pas à
l'extérieur parce qu'on souhaite que des
oiseaux puissent constituer leur nid en
fait qu'on puisse réellement cohabiter
dans nos habitats
alors là on a deux totems protectorat
situé derrière un autre observatoire
pour évidemment se reposer mais aussi
observer la faune sauvage et pouvoir la
ressens c'est tout l'aspect recensement
c'est aussi pour montrer bien ce que ça
apporte aux territoires que c'est
vraiment un refuge pour la faune mais
aussi pour la flore
donc c'est vraiment un point important
pour nous de montrer enfin d'observer et
de recenser les espèces qui vivent avec
nous souvent il ya des chevreuils qui
non seulement me laisse les approcher
mais qui presque marche avec moi qu'à la
fin il n'y a pas il n'y a pas de peur il
n'y a pas d'hostilité et ça c'est assez
incroyable
là on coupe les branches de saules pour
les planter en terre et en fait chaque
boutures va être un nouvel art boue ont
fait un trou donc ça c'est un mec tu
enfantin qui est lisse très bien que
mais on peut tout ça gradés nos
territoires et et retrouver un cercle
vertueux avec la nature en fait on est
parti avec cette idée qu'il fallait
incarner cette écologie dans la terre et
en fait ça fait que accroître ce
sentiment parce que quand on vit dans
les écosystèmes et ben on est bien plus
motivé pour les défendre en fait vivre
l'écologie
or seuls comme dirait monsieur rabhi
c'est assez compliqué est en fait le
fait d'y être de voir les pénuries d'eau
par exemple parce que cet été à notre
source d'eau elle s'est tarie un mois
plus tôt que l'année d'avant
ça fait une écologie qui vient de plus
profond dans notre être
avant on voyait beaucoup de statistiques
beaucoup de chiffres sur des écrans qui
montrait ces extinctions potentiel
d'espèces tous et des règlements
auxquels on doit faire face
mais le fait d'y être et le fait de
pouvoir le vivre ça fait que on a un
attachement beaucoup plus viscérale et
une volonté d'agir qui est beaucoup plus
forte que depuis la ville
[Musique]